given your experience in negotiating
with some of the most powerful and
influential leaders in the world what's
the key to negotiating difficult
agreements in geopolitics I start with a
big question if I look back on the
different negotiations I had when I was
in government either with leaders of
countries with representatives of
leaders or even with members of Congress
to pass
legislation the most important thing I
would draw back to would be trust I
think getting to know each other
understanding what was
motivating the other party to get to the
outcome and making them feel like you
weren't going to use whatever
information they gave you to benefit
yourself at the expense of them is
probably what I would call table Stakes
to have a shot at accomplishing anything
that was hard in
negotiation after that I would
say taking maybe a first principles
approach to what the outcome of whatever
problem you're looking to solve should
be now you have different kinds of
negotiations I always tried to create a
framework in the negotiation where it
wasn't me against you it was always
let's agree on what the outcome is that
we're trying to accomplish let's all sit
on the same side of the table and say we
want to get to this outcome how do we
get there really trying to create a road
map and so once you understand the
destination you want to get to the end
point then you'd have to work backwards
and really try to put yourself in their
shoes and try to understand what were
their motivations macro uh most of the
time you have to assume that a Leader's
primary objective was to stay in power
and so all decisions made would be made
through the framework of what it would
take to to do that and how would impact
their ability to do that and then
finally I would just say that in any
negotiation you have to understand the
power dynamics as well and you have to
then wait your approach in order to
maneuver pieces to accomplish the
objective and so um in areas where we
had stronger power dynamics I'd always
look at it and say what are the
potential Escape Routes where a
politician would say this is just the
reason why we can't get there and I'd
always think how can you try to
eliminate those Escape Routes or make
them much harder to accomplish then
ultimately think about what's the Golden
Bridge
that you want to create for them in
order to get to the other side where
they were motivated to get there because
it was in their self-interest to get
there but also because it helped
accomplish the different objective and I
have many examples that that I live
through with that obviously negotiating
uh in Congress for for prison reform I
had to form a lot of trust with uh
Democrats whether it was Hakeem Jeff or
dick Durban and then also on the
Republican side with um I had Mike Lee I
had Lindsey Graham I had Tim Scott uh
Senator Grassley and then uh also Doug
Collins in the house was tremendous and
you know every time we maneuvered
something we would get attacked either
from the left uh you know there was a
time we were being attacked by you know
Nancy Pelosi John Lewis uh for not being
you know inclusive enough and then there
were times that we maneuvered it we'd be
attacked from the right for maybe going
too far and ultimately we had to find
just the right place where we can get it
done and the same thing happened with uh
usmca where we were negotiating the
biggest trade deal in history hist of
the world which was $1.3 trillion in
annual trade between Mexico Canada the
United States of America and we were
able to form good trust with the other
side and try to say how do we create
win-win outcomes and ultimately we're
able to do something in a record time
that people thought was very uh hard to
do and both of them in a divided time of
the Trump Administration uh were by
partisan wins with with big big votes in
the Senate and the house uh you have a
lot of stories of this kind some
sometimes a soft approach sometimes a
hard approach like there's I think the
story where with BB there was a
potential like a dramatic election
coming up and you have to say
no no excuses no delaying you have to we
have to make this agreement I know BB
cares about Israel more than the
particular dynamics of the election like
you have to draw a hard line there yeah
but In fairness too like you know for
him during the time that we were dealing
with him he was always an election
versus election and then election and
you know what he was saying wasn't wrong
and I think he was more expressing his
concerns given the Dynamics and you know
we never held those concerns against him
we just said those are real concerns he
had we respected those concerns but then
we helped him prioritize to help
accomplish the right things and that's
ultimately what the partnership is right
I'm my job was to represent America his
job was to represent Israel and you had
other parties representing their own
interests and as long as you assumed
that you know people were acting mostly
in good faith you were able to navigate
areas where you didn't have you know
complete overlap of of priorities and
objectives just to go back to the trust
thing you sometimes see that with
leaders where they're kind of it looks
like they're trying to screw over the
other person when they're talking and
so not having that I think is a really
powerful thing for earning trust like
that people actually can believe that
your results driven are and are working
towards a certain end is there like a
skill to that like what is that genetics
you're born with that or is that
something like you develop so basically
it requires you to look at the game of
politics and not have a kind of cynicism
about it to where everybody's trying to
man manipulate you and actually just go
in with a kind
of open mind and open heart and actually
speak truthfully to people like on a
basic human level I would say that I
always would think about how can I be a
partner to others like I would want
somebody to be a partner to me and and a
lot of it comes from just my different
experiences in business I've had great
Partners I've had terrible Partners uh
my father uh you know again a lot of my
my childhood was I was exposed to
business my father uh you know on
Sundays he would take us to to job sites
and to the office with him instead of to
football games like my friends you know
fathers would do and so we're exposed to
business and what he would say about his
father who was an immigrant uh to
America came over with nothing and no
formal education but he would always say
a good deal with a bad part partner will
always be a bad deal and a bad deal with
a good partner you'll figure it out and
so going through some of the challenges
and that I had in my life early on
whether it was uh the issue with with my
father that we'll I'm sure we'll talk
about or even going through some you
know tougher financial times during the
great financial crisis I really learned
a lot about partnership and I always
thought how can I act in a way where I
could be the type of partner or friend
to others that I wish others would be to
me so when you look for a good
partner don't you think there's the
capacity for both good and bad in every
person so when you talk when you
negotiate with all these leaders aren't
there like multiple people you're
speaking to inside one person that
you're trying to um encourage catalyze
like the goodness in the human yeah so
so lead leaders are generally chosen by
their country and so
um my view was if I had an objective I
didn't get to choose who was the leader
of other countries my job was to deal
with that leader understand their
strengths understand their weaknesses
understand their power dynamics as well
you know one of my greatest takeaways
when I grew up I'd read the newspapers
about all these powerful famous people
and then as I got older and had the
chance to meet them and do business with
them and then ultimately uh you know
interact with them in government is I
realized that they're just like you and
me they wake up every morning you know
their kids are pissed at them their wife
doesn't want to talk with them you know
and they've got you know a set of
advisers around them one saying you know
let's go to war one saying let's make
peace one saying do the deal one saying
don't do the deal and they're all
thinking where do I get advice how do I
make decisions and so understanding the
true human nature of them and then the
different power dynamics around them I
thought was very key and so I didn't
have a choice do I deal with them or not
it was a function of how do you deal
with them effectively in order to find
areas where you have common interests
and then work well together to pursue
those common interests in order to
achieve a certain goal you uh first of
all you're incredibly well read I've
gotten to know you and I've gotten to
know Vanka and the the book
recommendation list is just incredible
so first of all thank you for that you
told me about the guns of August by
Barbara tuckman it's a it's a book on
World War I and I went down a whole
Rabbit Hole there he like an incredible
historian but anyway the there's a bunch
of stuff you learn from that but one of
the things you told told me is it
influenced your general approach to
diplomacy of just picking up the phone
and giving it a try so as opposed to
planning and uh strategizing just pick
up the phone yeah so so this was a book
I read uh way before the notion of
serving in government uh was ever even
on my mind or or reality and I remember
thinking about it reading it and
thinking how World War I started where
you had U you know somebody was
assassinated and then you had all these
different alliances that were created
and then in order to accomplish
objectives it triggered all of these um
people getting in bed with everyone else
because of documents that were created
without the intent of going to a massive
war and I think in the course of World
War I it was one of the greatest uh
atrocities that we've seen as Humanity
we've had 16 million people killed in
that war and I as I was reading the book
I remember thinking to myself even
though you know things are set in a
certain way go sit with somebody go talk
to them and say this doesn't make sense
this is wrong how do we create a better
pathway and as a civilian all my life
you know I would read the newspapers I
would I would I would you know observe
how different leaders would act but when
we have the opportunity to serve in
government and have uh the position you
realize you're not a civilian you don't
have the luxury of sitting back and
letting the world happen the way it's
happening you have agency and you have
uh the potential to influence the
outcome of things and one thing I've
seen is you know most political
prognosticators are wrong anyone who
tells you what's going to happen really
has no clue and it's not because they're
bad or they're not intelligent it's
because nobody knows and at the end of
the day the outcomes in the world are
usually driven by the decisions of of
humans and if you're able to come
together form relationships listen to
each other uh you can do that and one of
the great examples that I speak about in
the book is with North Korea whereas if
you remember in
2017 it was very intense when President
Obama was leaving office he told
president Trump that the single biggest
fear that he had and this is a time when
the world was a mess you had uh the
Middle East was on fire Isis was
beheading journalists and killing
Christians they had a califate the size
of Ohio Libya was destabilized Yemen was
destabilized Syria was in a civil war
where 500,000 people were killed Iran
was on a Glide path to a nuclear weapon
yet the single biggest fear he had was
North Korea it got compounded by the
fact that we get into office and
president Trump brings his generals
around and he's you know learning how to
interact with all the generals and says
okay what are my options and they said
calm down we've been using all of our
ammunition in the Middle East we don't
have enough ammunition to go to war over
there and he says let's not let's not
let that be due public let's try to
restock and come up with a plan yeah and
at the time there was a lot of banter
back and forth and uh you know I was
able to I got a call from a friend who
was a old business contact who actually
had done business in North Korea and he
said you know I'd love to find a way to
solve this and I was getting calls from
friends at the time saying I'm trying to
go to Hawaii for vacation should I not
be going is it not safe I mean we forget
we forget the psychology of how intense
that was at the time and then through
that interaction he C some of his
contacts in North Korea and then we were
able with the CIA to open up a back
channel that ultimately led to the the
deescalation the meeting between Trump
and Kim Jung good which led to a
deescalation so that was really the
mindset which was whenever there's a
problem just pick up the phone and try
and I think president Trump had a very
similar approach which was let's let's
give it a shot and he wasn't afraid to
go after the hard ones too and I'll say
one final thing on this which is that in
politics the incentive structure is just
much different than in the real world
right in the sense that you have a hard
problem then if you try to solve a hard
problem the likelihood of failure is
great whereas in the business world if
you're going after a hard problem we
celebrate those people right we we we
want our entrepreneurs and our great
people to go after solving the big hard
problems but in politics if you try to
take on a hard problem you have a high
likelihood of failure you'll get a lot
of criticism uh on your pathway to
trying to accomplish that if you fail
and then if you fail it has a higher
probability of leading to you losing
your opportunity to serve and so it's
just one of these things where people
want to play it safe which is not the
notion that that that really was taken
during the time that President Trump was
in office do you think it has to be that
way I think I think there's something in
in the human Spirit like in the public
that desires politicians to take
big take on the big bold problems right
like why why is it the politician need
to be so afraid of failure I don't think
it has to be that way and that's I think
one of the great lessons from the time
of the the Trump Administration he
brought a lot of people from the
business world into government uh the
business people have a much different
mindset than government people and there
was a lot of resistance and I think part
of why there was so much resistance was
because you know I think about it from
my personal sense was that if I was
successful with no traditional
qualifications to do diplomacy it meant
that all the people with traditional
qualifications and diplomacy didn't
necessarily need those qualifications in
order to be successful and that same
that same sentiment manifested it self
in many areas in government and and I
think that in the business world it's
it's outcome oriented it's results
oriented and you know what we would see
in in New York is there they would
stabby in the eye and DC they would stab
you in the back and it just became a
whole different Dynamic of of of how you
work through these different areas so
the answer is it doesn't have to be that
way you just need the right courageous
leader and that's why I'm so optimistic
about what the future of America and the
world could be if you have the right
people in power who are willing to take
on the right challenges and do it in the
right way so if we just lingered on the
North Korea and the deescalation and the
meeting what's the
trajectory from this could be the most
catastrophic thing that destroys the
world to you find back channels you
start talking and start arranging the
meeting like is there some insights you
can give to how difficult that is to do
in that in in the North Korea case which
seems like to be one of the more closed
off parts of the world and in the other
cases that you worked on yeah it's it's
always very challenging and especially
when you're going against the grain of
what's established right we did
something different to think that an old
business contact that I had could then
do it I mean that's the type of thing
that you know if the Press knew what we
were doing they would have you know
derided it and criticized it in Every
Which Way but that was one of the
benefits of operating very much below
the radar is that we were able to try
all these different things and not all
of them worked but some of them did and
you know but that is what's amazing
about the world right this could be the
biggest story on the front page of every
paper and they're inciting fear and
everyone and it's not illegitimate fear
I mean there were missile tests uh you
know over over Japan I mean you had a
lot of uh very CH big challenges with
that file and then all of a sudden we
make contact we go through negotiations
to set a meeting there's a meeting
between President Trump and Kim Jung gun
and then all of a sudden there's there's
a framework um to try and move things
forward um and again I think that
there's a lot of possibility there for
what
could happen if it's worked in the right
way I just want to know like how you
word that first email or text message
like what emojis to use like the hugging
Emoji I it's just personally I've gotten
to know a lot of powerful and uh rich
people and just it's funny that they're
all human just like you're saying and
like a lot of the drama a lot of the
problems can be resolved with just like
a little camaraderie a little kindness a
little like just actually just reaching
out we're all human beings and and
people want to be successful and people
want to be good and and you're right too
there's there's way more emojis involved
in diplomacy than I ever would have
expected but and every leader I'm sure
has their favorite emo this is also I
learned about people they use like they
there's the everybody has their go-to
Emoji like I usually go to the heart
very quickly Emoji there's some people
who go the hugging whatever that where
you're like doing the hugging thing
anyway uh this conversation quickly
turned to the ridiculous but to do
another book reference you mentioned the
book 13 days in September by Lawrence
right uh in discussing all the work
you've done in in Israel in the Middle
East I just want to ask you sort of the
interesting aspect of that book which is
the influence of the personalities and
personal relationships on these
negotiations you kind of started to
allude to that with the trust but how
much do the personalities matter in this
so going from North Korea to the Middle
East here to within Congress and all
that kind of stuff yeah completely in
every way I mean that that that's an
incredible book and it's a very
entertaining read it has obviously a lot
of good historical uh context on some of
the key players whether it was on Mor
sadad or manah or Jimmy Carter and and
and sance and and a lot of the others
who were involved with those
negotiations and the thing that I kind
of took from that experience was just
how personal it was and and again one of
my favorite stories from that book was
how Anar sadad who was a big big leader
he had a Mystic who was according to
this book again history I I I like
reading it but I always you know realize
that you have to notice that this is
just the perspective of a given author
that's writing it but the way that they
write this book was that he had an
advisor who was a Mystic and the Mystic
was having a back Channel with the
Israelis and the Mystic told saddat if
you go to Israel and you make a speech
at the knesset Bon is ready to give you
the Sinai and so um he goes to Israel
they set this whole thing up he goes and
gives the knesset they go for their
meeting after and Sadat says okay well
are we going to do this thing and ban
says what are you talking about I'm not
giving you an inch of our land and it
was just one of these things where it
was a
miscommunication that brought about the
symbolic visit of anoir sedat to Israel
and that was one of these Notions that
just made everyone think that something
was possible that they thought was
impossible a moment before actually we
had an example like that during our time
in government when we did the Abraham
Accords uh the first step of the Accords
was really a phone call between
President Trump uh prime minister
Netanyahu and Muhammad Ben zad who at
that point was the Crown Prince and and
deao ruler of the
UAE but all we had was a a phone call
and then a statement that was released
and what was interesting after that as
we said okay well how do we integrate
countries nobody's done this in a long
time and we were trying to figure out
all the issues and there's big
miscommunications between Israel and UAE
and we were navigating through all the
issues and so after a couple weeks I
said you know I've got to go over there
and try to sort through these issues so
we make a plan to go to Israel then
we're go to UAE and then a young
gentleman who worked with me named AI
burkowitz says well for flying from
Israel to UAE instead of flying on a
government plane why don't we see if we
can get an L plane and we'll do the
first official commercial flight and so
I said that's a great idea let's call
you know Ambassador Alba Yousef who was
a tremendous uh player in the Abraham
Accords working behind the scenes you
know day and night and was really a big
um a big catalyst so he calls youf and
he says sure no problem let's give it a
sh so so we go and we do it he says if
we can work out these issues what we'll
do so we go to Israel we do our meetings
we get everything back into a good place
we set up this this this trip over we
fly an LOL plane we fill it up at the
time it was during coid with a health
delegation we had the the financial
Ministry because we had to open up uh uh
you know banking relationships they
could wire money between countries uh we
want to get you know Health Partnerships
then we just had a lot of legal things
and National Security things we wanted
to start putting together together so we
do this flight and we end up uh Landing
in UAE and the picture of Us coming off
the plane being greeted by um you know
Emirates and toes with a l plane with an
Israeli flag on it just captured
everyone's imagination and so was one of
these things where it's like you work so
hard on the details the negotiation I
mean hundreds of hours to kind of make
sure everything's perfect and the one
thing that you do kind of you know yeah
let's give it a shot that image ended up
capturing everyone's heart so going back
to sadad that visit was very critical
and what was interesting was is
according to this book it happened
because of a miscommunication that was
the first part the second part of the
book that's just amazing theater and
actually the book was based on a play
was just going back and forth with all
of the the different methodologies that
they tried that failed but they kept
trying out it and then ultimately seeing
how the personalities were able to find
ways to make the compromise that
ultimately was a very very big thing for
uh more stability in the Middle East and
so amazing book I would highly recommend
it a very entertaining read and and
something that at least gave me
encouragement to to keep going when the
task I was pursuing seemed so uh so so
large I mean if we could just Linger on
the
personalities you you write in the book
that words matter or you you write in
the context of saying uh in the
diplomacy business words matter and then
you said that we're in the results
business it's a badass line but um but
if we just stick to the diplomacy
business and uh words mattering it seems
like one of the things you really
highlight that individual words can
really have like you can fight over
individual words so like how do you
operate in a world where like single
words matter I think you have to be
respectful to the craft that you're in
where words matter but then realize that
they don't matter as much and then also
focus on on the fact that you know the
actions are actually what's going to
matter more than the words and so you
have a difference between leaders and
politicians you know politicians are
there to say the right thing and to hold
the power leaders are people who are
willing to do things that will be
transformational from my perspective and
so when I would think about um
diplomacy words without actions or
without the threat of actions and that
was something that President Trump did
very well was that people knew that he
was willing to take action he was very
unpredictable and how he would act and
that made our words much more effective
in what they did so it's all a
combination but you know coming from the
private sector we were all about results
right if you're in government you can
work on something for 10 years and fail
and then retire and they consider you an
expert in the private sector if you work
on something for 10 weeks and you don't
have a success then you're unemployed
you know so it's it's it's a different
kind of notion and um and it was just
understanding the mentality and trying
to adjust and and bridging the divides
uh between the different trainings is
that the biggest thing you took from
your business background is that just be
really results focused it was just the
only way to be I mean if I was giving up
uh you know a nice life in New York and
if I was giving up you know the the
stuff that I really enjoyed the company
that i' I'd help build and you know the
the the the the life that I was enjoying
in order to do government I was going
there to make a difference and you know
we had to focus on it the other skill
set so there was a couple skill sets
that I found were quite deficient in
government uh first of all there was a
ton of amazing people I mean people talk
about the bureaucracy uh what I found
was is you had incredibly committed uh
passionate intelligent capable people
all throughout the government and what
they were waiting for though was
Direction um and then cover in order to
get there and so there were a lot of
tasks that I worked on whether it was
you know building the wall of the
Southern border where I was able to work
with uh you know Customs border patrol
um you know Army Corps of engineer
uh military DHS professionals DOD and we
basically all came together and then
once we had a good project management
plan we were able to kind of move very
very quickly I think we built about 470
miles of uh border barrier in about two
years basically and that was very that
worked very well because we basically
brought private sector project
management skill sets which uh which
were quite often missing in government
the second one is just you know we spoke
about negotiation earlier I would say
that most people in government it's just
a different form of negotiation than you
see in the private sector um and way
less effective in that regard which is
why I think it's good the more we can
encourage more people with private
sector experience to do a stint in
government and to really try to
contribute and serve their country
that's how our Founders I mean George
Washington and all the the founding
fathers they they were working on their
Farms they they left their Farms serving
government then they went back to the
farm and that was kind of the design of
you know the representative government
it wasn't a career political class class
it was you know people coming in to you
know show gratitude for the freedoms and
the Liberties that they enjoyed and then
you know you know do their best to kind
of you know help others have those same
opportunities that they had and then
they'd go back and live their lives and
so um so I think that there's a lot of
opportunity with our government of
people with more business mindsets who
are going to think about things from a
Solutions uh perspective go and
serve
that